welcome back to the quarter podcast and
welcome back to the corridor digital
podcast is this I get one more try and
if it still does it then that's just
that's it okay it's okay it's okay
that's like the the vibe of the podcast
you came here for excellence go to court
or digital youtube if you want jank come
here one more time okay that's welcome
back and the troubles of a zoom meeting
here we go we're live again this week
right here with you back for another
podcast born team who's gonna be over
this week so we're all gonna go out and
party together at a nightclub this
sensing shoulder knees shoulder sweat on
I heard that I heard that since numbers
were going down that we could all just
quit corn taining and do whatever we
wanted again is that right you heard
wrong Jake oh dang yeah I was really
excited Dori your Chancellor I am
looking forward to going to a party
though as soon as like someone can have
like a post quarantine party I will be
at that party there's sort of Club for
like the ones who are clean or it's like
look I've been corn G for two weeks I'm
clean and like you have a secret
handshake yeah that's established two
weeks prior and updated daily you know
we said
we started this we weren't gonna talk
about the corona I just had to get it in
you just had to get it in I mean you
know you know but that's the thing I
think it would have to be invite-only
you can't make it public you have to be
like hey hey you've been sheltering in
place haven't you gathering secret of
mine yeah other news I know people have
been wondering about the editors
submissions I did make a post about this
on Instagram last week but we had over a
thousand yeah that's a lot I've been
going through them for the last week or
so and I've got 20 to go as of right now
Wednesday evening wow that's pretty cool
impressive so I've got to get 20 through
the 20 more and then I've got 70 unless
all of those 20 go into the review bin
I've got 70 that are in the review bin
I'm gonna review those second a second
time and then send them to everybody
so get ready they'll probably be about
20 15 or 20 that'll and ultimately end
up sending so Jake when you go through a
thousand videos like a certain point you
know you've seen the footage of million
times well I guess a thousand times yeah
what are you looking for in something
like this well there's a couple things
in it is it is most certainly video
content dependent like not every video
is as hard and fast rules but for the
footage that we gave there are some hard
and fast rules number one was things
like things that I would look for to
tell me if I should continue watching
the video or not we're things like its
overall length just straight up off the
bat if it was over like 17 18 minutes I
you know after having watched about a
hundred of those
see what people were doing at that
length I realized like none of those
we're really meeting the requirements of
like you know there's no way they can
keep it entertaining for that there's
not enough in the footage yeah that's
the thing it's not footage that we've
actually edited ourselves yet right now
so there's like no context for for how
long it should be but discovering it
through that process yeah I didn't I
didn't start by just being like oh this
videos 20 minutes long there's no way
but after I watched about 30 of those
and I was like okay pretty much every
video that's that long can't be
entertaining because it I think makes it
impossible to be that entertaining do
you like do you ever go like all right
one minute let's see what you got for me
I saw so yo yeah well what I would do is
I before I even checked anything I just
click and I'll watch the first 30
seconds
yeah and that gives you a pretty good
idea of what the person's style is and
then from there I'll scrub and I'll look
for things like did they use b-roll how
do they set up moments did they not use
music there's a lot of people who did
not use any music at all oh yeah it's if
they just edited one story is that one
story over 10 minutes because you know
like just sitting there watching you
guys mess around on with a crash mat for
so it's like is like comes down to
things like do they use motion graphics
how did they use the footage did they
did they edit it chronologically after a
while to you begin to see like the way
that it was actually shot
chronologically and like there was a
moment in the crash mat footage where
Ren decides he's going to run up to the
top of the costume loft he's going to
use that on that edge well so there's a
moment in this footage and well Ren is
going up there Nick turns the camera
and he looks at Clint and Wes and they
do this whole other shtick for about 30
seconds and then and then the camera
goes back to Ren a lot of people that
were just editing chronologically left
that in there exactly in the actual
chronological point and what should
occurred in time when there's that
there's no real reason to use it there
you know it's like all you're doing at
that point is just scrubbing through
trimming it down leaving it in
chronological order but you're not
utilizing it towards the story which is
the thing that we saw right before that
was Ren creating a story point which is
hey I'm gonna go see if I can jump off
of this loft and now you're cutting away
to something and then coming back to it
simply because that's where that
happened in real time but not in service
of the story point yeah and so there's a
lot of that all over and when I saw
things like that you know and then I
created tears just so I didn't like miss
anything you know so I've got like five
tears that I put all the applicants into
and depending on how confident I feel
after the first two tears I can always
go into like the third and fourth ones
but I doubt I doubt that part of me
thinks that you should be so many in
that test
pardon me think she should give the same
test to both Dean and Matt I mean that's
how they've already done that test we
should do that actually we should that's
almost like the new benchmark or
whatever they come up with should be
kind of where the new yeah they have so
much practice now - did a lot of people
do like the teaser like before the logo
today yeah yeah almost everyone did that
oh my god you could do the storyline
sorry Dean and Matt like are like hey
we've got an idea we're gonna
reapply for the editors and say we can
work remotely
[Laughter]
free time alias dan and then they're
like oh yeah we live in Sweden and uh we
have we can help Sayid and Tim there was
a guy from Sweden who did his own brand
integration for himself
Wow there was that did that they did
they did integration mid-roll how and
why they hired that's great that is
clever pretty really fun I gotta ask
Jake what percentage of applications
didn't follow the directions of name and
were like yeah the format restrictions
honestly only like 0.3% 0.3 yeah nice
less than a percent so everyone was on
top of it this time ah yeah yeah
everyone did a great job with that so
and you know we got rid of the all the
all the BS stuff came in within the
first 24 hours and then so not excluding
that obviously and then there were some
kids that were like hey I'm 13 I don't
want the job but can you can you look at
my video and tell me how I can do it
better
oh wow so there's a couple of those but
yeah we've got 70 left that are in that
are like perspective for round 2 so now
I have to go through those 70 boil it
down and then yeah that'll be that 20
and then from there we'll reach out to
some of them for round 2 I got a close
question about this video some those
kids
yeah any of those videos a video or if
we if we actually applied the entire
studio for a day and like worked on
their video anything there that
potential are just blowing their minds
I mean I can pull it up right now was it
their own video or was it the actual
edited footage like as if they were
applying for it not expecting to get the
job well - I'll be dead honest with you
I did not look at them because as soon
as they told me in the subject of the
email that they were 13 and that they
weren't looking to get hired I just
moved on mmm there's a thousand of these
to get through yeah let me pull it up
let's see what this kids got you know on
this podcast I guess will describe the
video it looks like yeah well I actually
J give you share screen it will be in
the recording yeah that's true you can
either works in YouTube I wash it there
if you're listening to the audio only
it's on the youtube version will still
describe it though here in my internet
inbox looking for 13 year old I just
noticed that like my virtual backgrounds
like erasing my chair so just looks like
I'm sitting here like awkwardly holding
my elbows outwards is my comfortable
resting position LD like full screen you
can kind of tell if it's a chair here
but little thumbnail view it's really
weird there you go there's one a woman
I'm 13 and I'm not looking to get hired
I just want to ask if I did a decent job
editing this video and where I could
improve do you guys want to if I also
had an idea for a future video if you're
interested you guys want to see this
yeah you know obviously it's like that's
really sweet that you would send us a
video and just you know there is edit
wants to see what it's like so yeah
let's watch it let's let's take a look
at the Senate oh it wasn't even like I
know I can't get the job cuz I'm 13 it's
like I don't want to write I just want
the feedback his videos private
[Laughter]
a shot you know that moment name I'll
well yeah you failed
[Laughter]
you got mom's spaghetti all over your
chest now pretty sure pretty sure they
haven't seen a milder than 13 years old
vintage for them
all right well point a was there was a
lot of submissions and it was humbling
to see all of them and I'm really
excited to reach out to the round 2
people there were a few that I you know
when you're watching them and you're
slogging through hundreds of these and
you get to that one that's got that
shine to it you're like wow this this is
actually entertaining and I'm enjoying
it and it's like creative and there's
they're doing things that I didn't think
of and they're you know they're trying
things and they're making decisions
those good decisions yes what it is man
decisions making decisions that's art
yeah that's filmmaking well you heard it
here first the process is gone and you
will get an outreach email if you made
it to the next round
that's right nice probably post
something on social media when we say
those go out to just so for those we
didn't make it you'll know that uh yes
they've been reached out to a few and so
you don't have an email so Ren Ren's
been doing some interesting things since
he's been locked up in quarantine even
3d printing like but your own house or
something
not quite I've been trying to have the
printers going nonstop this whole time
printing something usually it's PPE
stuff for for health care workers
something like ear protectors for for
like masks and stuff because a lot of
nurses are getting like rashes on the
back of their ears just from having like
the straps on them
47 yeah so I'm printing a lot of that
also just in in my my New Year's
resolution that came in early February I
have decided to try to be a lot more
organized in my life and so I've been 3d
printing some some organizers I've got
like a little like wire clips and stuff
to help organize my ton of wires like a
little SD card holder thingy
what job what what caused you to want to
make that change in your life um mainly
my my inability to function in life and
you live life to the fullest
yeah what does that mean I I don't know
how to describe it it's it's uh yeah I
transitioning to working from home was
very difficult for me and and so and
especially just because I mean you guys
know how a cluttered my desk at work can
be at home it's advanced took a lot of
time to like straight up clean
everything reorganize actually my living
room looks spectacular now I will say
and I've just been trying to make an
effort to clean off my desk at the end
of every day and part of that is to help
I have places for things to go like I
have a 3d printed this little drawer
thing so all these different drawers
that oh and I could print more of these
too you know it's just on demand I don't
have to wait for three week Amazon
shipping yeah this is the only time in
your lifetime where 3d printing will be
faster than ordering those little like
storage things from Amazon yeah that's
like you know 3d printing is really cool
and it's you know it's spectacular for
prototyping but like the one thing that
didn't really take into consideration
back when we started was just like how
long it takes sometimes even just like
simple stuff there's like oh we great to
have like these little drawers I would
have to buy them but like it takes a
week to print them versus like you know
two days I am is on prime now it's not
always the case but in this particular
instance you can get it into the world
yeah yeah it really depends what you're
trying to print yeah like pretty much
the bigger the object obviously the
longer it'll take but there are some
things that are better too
print at home especially if you can like
customize it to specifically fit your
need oh dang where'd I put my clamps I
printed like the world's biggest clamp
mm-hmm yes I want to see that now
plastic clamp I think I put it in the
garage I'd have to go get it so is that
the biggest thing you cream screen clamp
it is great you know what carry on we'll
be right back with the clamp the clamps
yeah organization I did a lot of that
right before Gwen was born which was not
it was like an inadvertent organizing
set up yeah
and it's definitely paid off did you
feel that that like pre child's nesting
instinct or was it just part of yeah no
it was it was definitely that because of
well but there was also like an element
of I was combining offices with Sarah so
I had to like kind of consolidate all
the junk that I have in this room here
had put the guitars in the wall well
they already were I need more frickin
wall space I have too many now make a
wall out of guitars
I'm on the ceiling well it's not just
actually the actual guitar stuff it's
just uh you know you want a desk set up
that fits what you do so to speak um
very frequently you just end up having
like this slab of wood that you put
garbage on and the more you can like
just optimize or specialize towards what
you're doing and your use I think the
better so you know all the music gear
and stuff shelves
velcro strips you're like those layers
are pedals basically have like a desktop
pedal board now mmm the whole like
sliding keyboard underneath the desk
that saved like half the room but
definitely pays off and if you have the
time to do it definitely recommend it
when I get into my new house I'm gonna
start messing with with a little music
setup so you're gonna need to help me
with that you're talking about
but man that ability to just like right
now I've got the whole I've got the
whole video streaming set up you know
going and and it's really nice to just
sit down at my computer and be able to
like like if we're gonna play a game on
node know that it's already set up or if
we're gonna chat here know that it's
already set up be nice to do that with
electronic music to just sit down and
pull up the program and know that you
can immediately start recording
something yeah definitely it'd be nice
to get that way eventually back in the
office when we're back into you just
know on that note gaming setup podcast
set up just easy walk in the room and
start rolling definitely who's uh who's
discord is still on mine mindset popping
off I think it's one of you guys got a
deaf in your disguise deaf and boys me
it's going through the microphone
somehow I mean let's go through my
headphones how I'm hearing it on my it
might be you I definition
deaf dude it is it is even if you're
hearing it through your own ears and
speakers it's gotta be you but everyone
else has headphones so Randy D return
with your clamps I did I did so I
printed this clamp to begin with it was
just a small little clamp because I
needed to I'm doing some battery stuff
and I needed to like pin a vacuum
cleaner hose to my table so I was like
this will print overnight easy piece of
cake but then I was like I need a bigger
clamp
so I'm printed this awesome just a big
clamp it's three different pieces here
it's got like this damn knurled like
grip here at the end that's the C clamp
that's a proper seat clamp yeah pretty
much
yeah it's pretty strong cuz I was going
through my garage and I found like this
a few spools of filament that I bought
like three years ago and never used this
green one was this so I just went ahead
and printed this it took like 23 hours
dude your background is clean yeah that
hold back oh my god that whole area used
to be a disaster zone back there there
was a mass I don't know I didn't know
that there was not furniture over there
I thought there was furniture oh oh
there used to be a couch right here but
I've since pushed it up against the wall
which is great Wow yeah so do you feel
like you can accomplish anything now yes
I can accomplish anything I've ever give
my mind to what kind of video are you
gonna make next after your after your
exponential scale video well uh I'm
working on a script right now for a
video kind of talking impairing like The
Hobbit so Lord of the Rings but not not
so much about the movie specifically as
much as the method of modern filmmaking
in a post visual effects world yeah more
about that yes a preview it was a
previous totally okay so the general I
haven't finished writing it but like the
general like 3x structure to this thing
is kind of comparing Lord of the Rings
to the hobbits to the mandalorian and so
in Lord of the Rings they had they
didn't they weren't able to have a lot
of CGI and digital sets and all that
stuff so they made everything
practically in miniatures and big it
sure isn't in a lot of cases and then
put CG creatures or CG elements on top
of all that but using the real plate
photography of these miniatures to add
to what that meant is that once they got
the footage they are locked in they
can't alter it or change it or add notes
to like the camera move or whatever
that's it and then you know fast forward
another 10 years or so suddenly around
the time of Avatar and The Hobbit Matt
akin from what a digital was explaining
this to us on the couch for VFX artists
react room he was here is like he said
them and every other VFX house on the
planet essentially was making the
transition to just doing completely
digital environments and that gave a lot
more freedom to the director to control
the look of shots
I'm gonna propose that that actually is
a bit of a downside kind of like a bad
thing because it gives a little bit too
much freedom it removes the constraints
that kind of helped feed creativity and
and so you started seeing a little bit
more of a like kind of a generic looking
washed style of visual effects that you
start seeing over the last 10 years or
so and now then fast-forward again to
actually putting that creative control
back into the hands of the camera
workers the cinematographer the director
on set with the whole idea of virtual
productions and LED walls being able to
capture everything in camera a fantasy
like form in DeLorean they shot I don't
know like over a dozen different fantasy
places like you know no TV show could
have possibly shot at all these places
on the budget that they are shooting on
and they were able to do it all in one
studio which traditionally you'd have to
do in a green screen room which would
have cost a tremendous amount of money
and would have been a huge pain and
wouldn't have looked that good
so that's kind of like how this all
plays out and then I I'll have to figure
out some sort of thing to say to tie it
all together and give it some meaning
yeah so well that's kind of in line with
the stuff that you've been playing
around with Sam on the last part yeah
yeah definitely
well it's just like after it's visiting
that Lux stage it's been really
inspiring so I've just committed a lot
of my free time over the last few months
to figuring out how to use unreal to do
pretty similar stuff obviously we won't
have this giant multi-million dollar LED
wall kind of setup but I think you can
just just do the whole thing virtually
just characters environments everything
and yeah it will kind of look like a
video game but you know you just for now
create content that kind of fits that
look your first foray into this yeah
well no we saw actually balloting right
now we had a little little session about
this today but we were like I was
thinking all right we're all in
quarantine you know we're all hunkered
down
we're not meat enough for physical
shoots so what's a thing that we can do
with that constraint and so very quickly
we just got to the idea of like let's do
like one of those VFX artists react
parodies except it's videogame
characters talking about videogames as
if as if it's a working profession so
basically right now I've got Clint Nico
I've got myself
we've I've got like face tracked models
that were scanned of everyone not gonna
live from what I've seen so far sorry to
interrupt but the fidelity of the models
for you Nico and Clint's are quite
impressive they're they've got a certain
amount of like obvious jank to them but
at the same time it's also like higher
quality than I would have expected yeah
well I think it's that kind of place to
the fact that I used photo scans instead
of like trying to use some sort of like
face generator to get a 3d model and so
that kind of adds a little bit of work
to take a 3d scan of a face and like
chop it up and basically rig it but you
know the plus side is just it looks a
lot more natural because it's a
photographic texture and the face like
has all the unique you know geometry of
each person so basically the way we were
thinking of shooting this thing we did
it kind of like a practice run today
where we're basically taking some like
really funny video game clips and over
like discord we would just play the clip
like it's a react video and we'd all
just chat while watching the clip and
just like you know crack jokes and then
basically we'll take that edit it
together like kind of like audio only
and I'll use that audio track for the
video to then basically animate
everything so so it's kind of like kind
of like doing a yeah a cartoon in a way
some work for ya
so you're gonna do you're gonna do
straight up like a
shoulde dubbing hmm yeah I'm faced
dubbing yeah exactly
why not have like Clinton echo use their
own phone in that app to do the actual
animation capture I'm sure you discuss
this way yeah just it's too many too
many like too many things to deal with
they're like I'm I barely have a grasp
on doing it like myself and so having
like trying to coordinate it with three
people like doing it on different
machines yeah I just it's it's kind of
it's above my skill level right now so
but you know like you know I can do some
neko faces and some Clint faith because
now it means that both Clinton Iko are
gonna be basically caricatures of
himself now because you're just gonna be
like yeah
Niko here people just listening to
podcasts and it's just a weird video
game interpretation of me that has like
an extra wide mouth and video game eyes
and a more animated the teeth are kind
of jacked up the reason I'm working on
but the it's crazy a will moves though
yeah well that's because right now I've
got an iPhone down below that's Jerry's
mod Garry's Mod Niko you've made Garry's
Mod [ __ ] right here
[Music]
that's a cool shot I'm so impressed
oh no this part really makes me angry
because because because premise of this
piece that the characters on the couch
are video game characters who yeah have
played four games
[Music]
he was here he's there the whole time
yeah my name is Clint yeah so right now
it's basically yeah they're uh it's like
we're taking it from the angle that
these are video game professionals like
professionals in the video game games
not like so it's so it's so it's
fictional but when we talk about the
games it's like it's like a half blend
of talking about real-world video game
mechanics and the other half is us
making up like this
goofy stories from set or the experience
is working on these games yeah that's
okay so as if you're devs not as if your
characters no no if like someone had to
physically hold the game camera or
someone had to like actually coach this
game character into giving a performance
here's an example
so in first-person shooters you know you
know you always see some pair of hands
well Sam's character is the one that
does the hand activation blue the hands
in the doom 2016 that was Sam the hands
that he saw in half-life one was
actually his big break into the industry
they need like a hand guy he like he's
got the best reload animations these
characters react to CGI in game hand
renders well yeah basically that's one
way to put it but yeah it's it's it's
definitely a little bit out there but
the thing is is that like all the stuff
were like pulling up in the clips or are
are either like interesting like
familiar clips from games people are
playing like popular games or they're
they're like just like really weird
glitchy clips that we then attribute
those glitches to like someone on set
quote-unquote screwing out their job you
know there's like a safety or physics
coordinator that was looking out that
day do you know how people die man you
think it's funny but that's how people
get seriously injured
yeah so very well and stop beyond beyond
fixing cheat all your bones could
detached yeah and then all the sudden
you can't be written directly yeah so
but yeah it's going pretty well what is
what is head what is head 3d Nico what
on the left on the left extra that's an
unwrapped texture right there oh dude
your heads all like split that's the
weird like so wonderful and mapping you
can see the sides my head and the front
of my head off solid someone so you can
see even the back of your head it's like
it's have a profile but not it's weird
that is just the skin being so massive
on either side dude I just have massive
skin I think the amount of skin yeah so
yeah there's my little face testing zone
where I've got all the faces linked up
it's really creepy yeah so Wow oh yeah
then here then let me let me just show
you the last cool part
let me screen share again because lo oh
hey what's up everybody
now I'm on the screen there's Christian
not responding actually just gonna be
seen the gridview so yeah this is cool
this is the cool thing
just let the mouse open everything
everything's kind of locking up right
now for some reason but here we go guys
oh my god got it how do you guys on all
that yeah there you go now people can
see that's crazy
okay here's the last thing I can show
you guys how easy is it to make one of
those facial map things like can you it
takes a few hours to get it working
really there's some easy like stuff that
happens at the beginning but then the
hard part is assigning all the blend
shapes which are all the different
facial expressions and that takes a
little bit of manual labour anyways
here's the here's the fun stuff here
which is the virtual studio oh yeah
Vincent we come in the last time I saw
it the studio looks like it just looks
great a picture like actually yeah yeah
for real so so it I'm not gonna like
really show it like in full because
there are a lot of glitchy stuff glitchy
parts but when you throw in some like
depth of field like this yeah if they
look pretty pretty natural again like
when you scan the studio that you also
just get all the lighting baked into it
so just get actual photo real lighting
it really goes a long way towards making
it look good yeah so yeah control is
awesome yeah man unrealised such good
like graphics capabilities it's pretty
crazy there's always that issue in video
games or like the stuff that's out of
like that's in focus like the edges
blend into that a focus background sees
halo so for those of you guys who don't
know about this right now what we did is
a couple of months ago we had a guy with
a Leica VLK 360 camera come by the
studio and you did a full lidar scan of
the entire studio and then using this
software system that they have basically
linked together all these different
captures that he got from around the
studio which created one single
image of our studio that has all
adjustable lighting and all adjustable
focus and all adjustable space where you
can place the camera within that 3d
space and so we're using that to like
create our set if you mix it there's one
link the last thing here which is we
can't do a react video without that
green couch I showed some of you guys
this last week but I made sure that the
couch is like super on point so you can
take a look here it's good color you
nailed there I like that you can see the
photos that's crazy it's like actually
such a good detailed leather texture
yeah your skin is this a mall is this a
model of a couch or did you say it's a
model it's the closest one I could get
that was free yeah there was like a nice
one that was like a hundred bucks but
that was like identical to the others
but yeah you know what the right
textures on it it's like wow that's
pretty solid well good and I got up that
like the nice material settings so it's
got that like leather shine to it but uh
yeah so it's pretty it's pretty crazy
looking it's like it kind of looks like
we rendered it in like cinema 4d or like
an actual like good rendering
application real-time say that say that
it this video you know is like our foyer
into this technology and then we want to
go out and we want to make another one
if we want to make a video that's set in
say a space environment or what have you
where do we get the actual set from oh
geez well how do you you render that and
no it's basically the same
you do it any other way you just you
gotta find some assets and you gotta put
materials on them and you got to drop
them in okay so it's not gonna end up
looking very video game II I mean it
depends it really depends you can put a
lot of work into it and it won't so if
you yeah it depends on what you're
trying to go for it's like if are you
going photo-real well then put a ton of
time and money and effort into it and
you're trying to go less photo-real then
it's pretty easy also video games tend
to look like video games because they're
so optimized to be able to run at real
time at high frame rates on most
machines whereas if you know you're only
gonna be doing this on like one powerful
machine and you can kind of get away
with doing the really little frame rate
cuz you're just gonna compile all the
frames together it's like you can
actually crank those settings and make
it look really exactly well currently
this is still this is all the whole
studio set I have built here is running
it like I can run at it like 60 FPS in
real time and I probably could push it a
little further just fine but yeah like
I'm using this super high polygon like
models for that the scan is not
optimized for like real time stuff but
as friend was saying like if I'm
rendering and making camera angles and
cuts and actually setting up like a
cinematic at the end of the day when I
want to render it out it you can there's
a feature where basically it will just
render it frame by frame and but but
even still the frame the frame by frame
is almost still real time but if that
way it outputs it a nice smooth frame
rate so what kind of if you could do a
series with this check what kind of
serious would you want to make with it
like say I'm being ordered or channel
anything your heart desires no but
whatever what are you do you desire this
is you you read the one I already
already like three different things I
mean there's there's plenty we could do
that we could try that Mars gang one
since they already built out of Mars
gang would be perfect for this yes
that's the first thing that came to my
head it would I would yeah for that like
you know the only thing that gets tricky
when you start doing this real-time
stuff is like when characters interact
with objects because you know it could
look like a video game if it's like I'll
just grab something and then think and
it like sticks to their hand and like
getting that kind of stuff smooth is
like the hard part what are the
logistics of like shooting green-screen
assets for it is that impossible or is
that useful like a live play
yeah life points live person yeah well
it's gonna be like a normal green screen
shoot basically you know your school
still have all your issues of like
matching lighting and all that kind of
stuff and trekking maybe not tracking
your camera so maybe you can adjust the
lighting in the well I yeah it's like I
don't want my world to have the same
shitty lighting that we're using on a
green screen set I mean what is he just
like you know you build up this in your
video game to replicate the lights that
we have available to you in real life
and then just make sure your lighting
with the same things yeah you could but
but you still deal with that issue of
like are you well like what's gonna be
real like are the tables and objects
you're gonna interact with well say what
it wanted suddenly Nicko's you know eCos
field that he's got in this background
reminded me of a pub g-series that we
could do and say there's a man running
around inside of like okay if he's
running
well he's not it's not a green screen
[Laughter]
series about a character in a battle
royale environment and he's running
around he's interacting with objects
obviously so wouldn't be that hard in
terms of like oh we need a we need a
house where somebody can go into we need
home-like residential objects game
objects that you can interact with so I
would say the moment you have a live
character I think you don't want to use
unreal because I think you want to use
like cinema and octane and like you have
a real flesh-and-blood person so you
want your environment to look as like
physical as possible and unreal like can
get really close with some tricks but I
would say at that point you might as
well just like do your scene with an
early one do a
seem like that but on the moon because I
want to do this video about the moon and
it'd be really cool to be able to talk
as if I'm standing on the moon while
while saying whatever it is I'll be
saying with a moving camera on a green
screen using five trackers and as much
virtual reality or sorry virtual
production stuff as possible but so then
what do we what do we do we need
anything real like grey dirt and a moon
suit or like or what do you actually
capture anything live or other than
yourself whatever's not on a green
screen
anything not keyable would be captured
so you can we can do that where you have
like a floor say how I have it or who
gave it to me on my phone right now that
tick-tock it will record video and
record a for the camera animation
obviously camera move at the same time
and it's currently working I set my
floor plane all right and then I hit
record on my video and it's got it the
whole environments 3d tracked and it
syncs that up to your video I have it
working right here you put it in your
computer and then you can just drop your
visual text objects into the scene
without having to track the scene yes
you don't have to motion track it it's a
choice we go back how does that data to
your phone so much better than you like
professional cinema cameras these days
it's like because it's using a million
freaking sensors in here dude I know our
selection helps where it's like it's the
exact calibration of the lenses on here
that helps the moment you start putting
your own stuff on there it's over you've
seen how like phones have like three or
four lenses on them now right yeah I
remember like I made this prediction
about ten years ago that in about a
decade
we're not going to have cameras we're
just gonna have lenses with a chip on
the back and this is action kind of
becoming that they just put all the
lenses into one package or they're
having in a box of individual lenses
here's just a cube that contains all the
lenses and the tips just a permanently
cross all them onto the same computer's
a lens box it's pointing at things you
just decide which processing chip you
want to use cuz think the imaging chips
aren't the expensive part the lens is
the expensive part so at a certain point
the camera is gonna be like you know the
chip on the back of the lens is gonna be
a couple hundred bucks the lens itself
is like that you know
$8,000 lens yeah we're getting super
close to that it's taken on the form of
a bunch of lenses packed under the front
of your phone right now but whoa that's
pretty much it yeah I should shoot a
shooting like render a little demo so
you guys can see the quality of the
track on this sucker yeah what can you
give me your source for the serology
conversations cool so you guys are
familiar with like neural networks I can
identify an image right it's like you go
into Google and like you upload an image
you can say like this is a picture of a
boy or a picture of a tree or you know
whatever right
hmm and it's not like you know it's just
an arbitrary thing it's based around a
computer just learning how to how you
know to apply different weights and
values to different clumps of pixels you
know that you have a correlating pattern
to being this an object like a tree
tends to be green it tends to be
vertical it tends to be wider on the top
from the bottom and like you know it's
not that explicitly of a defined pattern
but that lends itself to creating a
pattern that eventually a computer can
recognize so some people are like you
know be interesting what if we made a
noise pattern that like on a per pixel
basis you can put on top of an image and
it just changes like the values just a
little bit to basically you
balance that neural network which is
literally just a series of you know
weighted networks basically it
imbalances that and changes the output
so you can give it say you know a
picture of a house and it'll return this
is a bus just because like you revalued
some pixels a little bit in the correct
pattern throughout the screen that's
been it something like the AI measures
until against the result it's called an
adversarial noise pattern where visually
it looks exactly the same so looks like
a picture of the house but everything's
been tweaked so slightly in a certain
pattern that the the visual code
basically contains a hack to break the
AI just how like you know back in the
day with dial-up modems you pick up the
phone you'd hear the noise and that's
the data adds noise you know this is the
data as a visual noise pattern that's
literally programs hacking programs
exactly it's it's a it's it's a piece of
data represented as visual noise but
when interpreted by the AI it becomes
data again they're in and then it breaks
the AI it's almost like it's not a virus
but it's kind of like a similar thing
where like it's kind of a hack yeah
question is because the neural network
does kind of emulate how our neural
patterns work can you make an
adversarial noise pattern that affects
people that affects people yeah I'm
gonna say absolutely because there are
already so many different illusions and
stuff like that that mess with our
brains that freak us out like you know
like the patterns of like all those
little dots and you see darkness between
it but it's not actually there it's like
you can poorly come up with some sort of
like design thing that'll just like
brain there's already stuff like that
though have you seen that that image of
the painting of the tool there's a bunch
of stuff yeah I got one I got a picture
right here that like it's kind of just
that it's the adversarial noise thing
like you're gonna feed this to a
computer probably recognize exactly what
it is but if I chose to you you'll look
at it from afar but yeah it's just a
picture of some junk and then you'll try
to look at it more closely and I dare
you to identify a single object in this
picture from afar it looks like a bunch
of just objects no yeah I can figure out
the SAR but when it uh when you look at
it here let me just show my spoon
identify snap I want you identify one
Audion already alright sure but you've
seen a desktop let me try this again
what I don't even look at that and see
like those are a bunch of objects that
can wreck it it looks like a deer I see
an ear in there what is this a picture
of looks like I said a garbage bag in
there it almost looks like some presents
looks like if bags it also looks like a
hoarders house it also looks like
grandma's craft table yeah it looks like
like advent calendars and a bunch of
plastics yeah it's like there's a bunch
of like sewing tchotchkes or whatever
like in the back corner like on a rack
or something but that's exactly what it
is it's basically just a bunch of little
elements from pictures like cobbled
together by an AI in a sense in a way it
makes sense like weird you know things
would tend to go but because it's not
actually a picture of anything it's
broken when we look at it up close so to
me that's kind of an example of an
adversarial noise Network for a human
being whereas like you can show that to
a computer and computer would I probably
identify a bunch of objects in there but
we can't because it doesn't quite make
sense but the thing is like could you do
that like you trained something where
it's like I play a certain sound or like
blink lights at you a certain way it
shuts all down all your senses and you
can't process something well we've done
the thing where if you listen to your
own voice slightly out of sync yeah
that's like that's like a great example
of a totally not that crazy yet totally
works example of adversarial noise we
did that with bread and the no that's
just like so maybe like if you look
close it's actually something else
that's just playing on you know general
forms and light like from far
it looks like two people but up close
the details pop out you see that
something else okay they kind of mess
with that effect and watchman actually
write that little blinking flashlight
that kind of zone them out and like yeah
like theoretically that being like an
adversarial yeah I like it like it was a
light and it kind of basically made them
so you can control them or like you know
kind of zoned him out yeah
actually not the more thing about Jake's
background the more it actually kind of
does seem like it's an adversarial noise
pattern see like the adversarial noise
pattern is the high level noise that
makes it look like to people whereas the
actual image isn't that it's the people
people yeah it's like two people sitting
down with stuff but like the way that
the pattern plays like our eyes I didn't
identify the macro patterns like oh
here's the general shape of a head and
here's the profile but no nose and a
chin and hair you know even though
that's not actually what the picture is
of so yeah that kind of is man human
beings are so basic so basic okay but
you're talking about here let me pull
this up you're talking about this kind
of stuff like there it is like this yeah
exactly so it looks like an image of a
truck but when it breaks down the AI
interpreted totally differently yep so
what's the use what's the what's the
usefulness of stuff like that
well one usefulness is that it can help
you build a more robust say I like let's
say let's say you'd make an AI that can
detect deep fakes yeah and then you have
your deep fake maker well you just put
those together and once the AI can
detect defects can no longer detect deep
fakes and your deep fake is getting
better you know so you just play them
off each other well it becomes an arms
race a machine competition to improve
the machines yes
actually I'm basically just quoting two
minute papers at this point but if you
guys just go check out that guy's
YouTube channel to channel fantastic
papers two minute papers yep but uh you
know if anything the adversarial network
just the thing that I find really cool
about that or sorry that they have
material network but the adversarial
noise is
that it's basically taking what's almost
like code you know and like fine-tuned
elements and it's turning it into
something visual
so it's abstracting it out of it like
the medium that it should be in but once
the AI reads that noise pattern you know
all that stuff becomes data again cuz
just becomes you know value points
so you're basically translating like a
hacked like piece of code that'll break
something through one medium into an X
it's like having like a sound that if
you play it next to you like your
chromecast it breaks your chromecast
like it's it's cool stuff like that but
I'm like really into like imagine being
able to show a pattern to like a web
camera and then it crashes your computer
which by the way happened in old red
cameras there were patterns that would
crash the old red cameras so basically
this is a story or an amount of Sony
they're filming at a certain spot up in
Griffith Park and it was like a like a
vehicle following a vehicle and after
time the car around a corner the camera
would crash and this is the red one back
when is basically like a PC and then
like a lens on the front and like why is
it crashing they're trying different
things they call it bread and so you
know way red works is it records into
raw but it's it actually it's a type of
compressor ah where it basically will
take different patterns and compress
them and it was these trees it was the
pine needles on these trees that weren't
like impossible for the codec to
compress because there's like all the
horizontal lines like bunched together
then layered on top of each other
there's no way for like the codec was
breaking as it writes you take this
visual pattern and like simplify it into
you know the codec and the camera would
crash on the glass one on the red one so
it's crazy it's crazy that you could
point a picture putting the camera at a
certain picture and it would make the
camera shut down because it couldn't
process that picture cuz the way the
pattern was organized and I bet you you
could do the same thing with all regular
cameras these days I bet you could put a
pattern towards it that overloads like
the processing unit and now the
challenge there is just finding what
exactly that pattern would be yeah we
could do it on all the facial
recognition cameras man and then they'd
never be able to get us man do they have
that they have shirts you can wear and
stuff that like have those patterns that
the facial recognition programs look for
it looks like your shirt think it's
really confused and tries to track that
and your face just goes on scanned and
now with all the covert stuff you can
just put on your face mask there's that
too
yeah straight yeah now it's socially
acceptable to walk into a bank with a
gas mask and sunglasses on like Adrienne
has been doing I don't know if anybody
like you know so follows Adrienne on
Instagram Adrienne's definitely at the
upper echelon of people who take this
very seriously gas masks on gasps man
yeah in this hood up of course the hood
is always up yeah sweet alright guys
well that's a great podcast I had
enjoyed this conversation immensely and
if you enjoyed this conversation
immensely dear listener please consider
subscribing to the corridor cast and if
you want to listen to us in the non
video way if you want to listen to us
off of youtube well we are available
anywhere that you can find podcasts so
including our website all over again
did it on the tail end you beat it calm
all right thanks everybody talk to you
later